My name is Gene Gurkoff, and
I'm the founder of Charity Miles.
Charity Miles is a free app that
allows people to earn money for
charity whenever they walk,
run, or bike.
I was a finance lawyer for a number of
years, and when I was in law school,
before that I started running marathons
to raise money for Parkinson's research,
in honor of my grandfather
who has Parkinson's.
And I figured if I got
enough people together,
then collectively we would
have the clout of a celebrity.
And then companies would
want to sponsor us.
The first technological project that
I worked on was actually while I was
still a lawyer.
And I thought it would be really cool if
we could make something where we could
crowdsource what we think the law should
be and it totally failed [LAUGH].
But it was a really good experience.
If you're going to create an app or
you're going to be an entrepreneur,
in any field, I think there
are many moments of failure.
How you spin those failures
into a learning lesson or
a success that I think
are the most important.
I never would have thought of
Charity Miles if I hadn't had failures.
Before I got the engineers I
talked to a lot of people.
Just ran the idea by them just
to see what they thought.
Then I got the developers and we worked
on wireframing and designing everything.
All these features that,
you know, we had in there,
crammed in there, we are going to
take that out, take that out, so
we ended up with something
that just did one thing.
We just choose from over 30
world-class organizations from
Wounded Warrior Project to Feeding
America to World Wildlife Fund, ASPCA.
I'm going to choose the Michael J Fox's
Foundation for Parkinson's Research,
in honor of my grandfather.
And then we're going to go for
an outdoor walk, and
now thanks to Johnson & Johnson,
we're able to earn money for
Michael J Fox Foundation for
every mile that we walk.
And this little mile counter down here
shows us how far we have walked and
if we press this we can see more so
we can again see how far we've walked.
And we can also in real time, the amount
of money that we've raised for
the Michael J Fox foundation.
And you know,
every mile really does matter.
So, as you continue to walk, you'll be
earning more money to cure Parkinson's.
And if you scroll down,
you can get a little bit more
information about Johnson & Johnson and
the other things that they're
doing to support great charities.
And when you're done, you just press the
stop button and finish, and that's it.
Very simple.
Whether you're a social good app or just
an app, try to create value versus hype.
Try to create an app
that makes people happy,
that makes people healthy,
that improves life somehow.
You're going to have to tell investors
about it, you're going to have to tell
your family about it, you're going to
have to tell your friends about it.
And if it's not something you love
then it's going to be really boring.
I never get tired of talking about
Charity Miles because I love it, and
I feel good about being able
to share this with people.
So I think it would be great if the next
generation of entrepreneurs could
use apps to harness the power of crowds
to drive major advances in science.
The phone has so much on it from
the accelerometer to the GPS that it's
monitoring all this data
about us all the time.
And that data is super critical for
Alzheimer's, for asthma, for
heart disease those being able to
use phones and apps to crowdsource.
That type of scientific is
going to change the game.
I would tell potential developers
to do something that they love.
It's the thrill of a lifetime,
they should do it.